okay hi there
welcome back to another episode of
science and technology q
a for kids and others
so i see a lot of questions saved up
here and uh
let me start looking at these okay it's
a question from zack here
are research papers useful how should i
write them and when
you know there's different there's
different levels of answering that
question
for me learning stuff
i find it really useful to have a
project that i'm doing some question
that i'm trying to answer
that's the way i learn stuff if it's
just a question of oh you're supposed to
learn this topic
go read this book and learn it
i find it much more difficult to an
interesting way absorb material
i find it much more interesting if it's
like here's this question
can i answer this question let me try
and push forward and answer that
question and learn what i need to learn
to be able to answer the question and
turns out you can there's a great art in
figuring out what's a good question to
ask
and it's often the case that there are
really good questions
that maybe can now be answered because
we have tools for example computational
tools
that let us address those questions that
people have never had before
and so you can get even if you think
you're a pretty junior person
in pretty sort of early stage person in
some particular area
you can get to the point of being able
to answer a question that nobody's ever
answered before in that field
potentially using new tools or maybe
just because you thought of a better
question to ask
and it's always to me it's like people
often as they think about these
different fields they say
oh that's a question surely somebody
must have answered that question
don't assume that just because it may
seem like an obvious question doesn't in
any way
mean that it's been answered in fact we
see that in
in in these uh sessions people will ask
questions and i can sometimes tell you
well it seems like an obvious question
but guess what i know nobody knows the
answer to that question
uh about something in science or
whatever else so you know
just if you're learning about something
you say i wonder about this this
and this it might be that yes actually
that question is well answered
it might be that that question has never
been answered it might be that that
question you haven't quite
defined the question well enough and
there is an answer if you define the
question well
you kind of need to learn more to define
the question well but i think it's a
a a terrific thing to sort of do
research as you learn
things and for me using computational
language using our wolfram language
stack and so on that's the way to kind
of uh be able to pull in
kind of artifacts from well the present
or the future or something
to apply them to things which are
questions today and so
you know in in whatever area you're
looking at it's like
um what are the obvious questions
can i use some of these methods some of
these computational methods
to perhaps have a different way of
answering that question than people have
ever had before
now when it comes to writing research
papers
you know to me things often only really
make sense to me
when i'm actually trying to write them
down and or or explain them to people i
mean that's part of the reason i like
doing these uh
these sessions is because uh you will
ask me all kinds of questions where i'm
not sure i've ever particularly thought
about the answer that question before
and the effort of trying to explain the
answer really helps me understand what's
going on
so to me sort of writing the research
paper
is part of the whole story of doing the
research
often one of the things when you're
doing computational kinds of things
it's like you're going to make some
great picture that's going to indicate
what's going on in your research
sometimes one can make the mistake of
saying
i'll i'll write the stuff first and then
i'll make the great picture at the end
because i'm only going to need it at the
end
that's a big mistake you should make the
great picture
as soon as as early up front as possible
because that's going to be the thing
that really shows you
what's going on once you have that great
visualization that
sort of pulls into one picture all these
different things then
you know that that's the thing which is
going to explain
what's going on to you and you don't
want a situation where you've written
this whole long document and they say
now i'm going to add this great picture
you make the picture you say oh my gosh
that picture shows something it's
completely different from what i
described in the rest of the document
whoops i have to go back to the
beginning and redo the whole thing
no get that picture up front
so that it helps you understand what's
going on as you hope it will help other
people understand what's going on
now in terms of of uh
you know sometimes you'll be writing
something there's a question of
of being honest when you write so to
speak that is
don't try and gloss over things that you
sort of say
whenever somebody says and i i have to
admit that i i catch myself doing this
well not so often these years because
i'm aware of it
whenever you say it's obvious that
that's usually a very bad sign it
usually that's the thing that's
extremely unobvious and may not even be
correct
and if you find yourself writing some
document
and about explaining something
and you end up with something where
you're kind of glossing over it
you know i suppose i have this problem
because i've i've gotten a lot of
practice at writing in my life
and so i kind of know i can sort of
elegantly write my way through lots of
things
but i have to kind of make sure that i
really understand it i'm not just making
some elegant statement
in fact sometimes i'll make some
wonderfully elegant statement i'll be
very proud of that elegant statement
and then i'll realize it's just a patch
it's not really addressing it's not
really teasing the ideas apart
in the best way it's just making an
elegant statement which one can sort of
write through and read through
and i kind of with great regret have to
throw away my elegant statement
um because you know i've managed to sort
of peel it back to understand what the
real story is underneath
um so sometimes it's it's kind of an
enemy
of clear writing is you know you
suddenly you get this very elegant
statement you managed to put these words
together in a way
that sounds really good but you realize
it's not actually the clearest way to
explain what's going on
it sounds good but it's not the clearest
way to explain what's going on
um excuse me
so when it comes to getting into sort of
more professional research papers
uh you know my point of view is if you
do research
and you can figure something out or even
clarify
some particular issue that's a good
reason if you can write a paper that
people will understand it's worth
writing it
if you don't have anything to say or
you'll write something nobody's going to
understand well there's no point in
writing it
when you get to the point where you're
for example doing professional science
or you're aiming towards professional
science um
there is a certain mandate effectively
in professional science that you know
people are expected to effectively write
such an essential number of papers per
year it varies
the number and the number of co-authors
and things like that varies with the
field of science
like an area like mathematics there are
fewer co-authors
in other areas like medicine there are
often many many co-authors
um and so on and they and the the
conventions about sort of
whose name goes on the paper and what
order and all this kind of thing
it varies from field to field but
fundamentally if you're a professional
scientist you're kind of expected to
write
some number of papers per year and and
honestly sometimes the things that
people write are very boring
and nobody's ever going to read them and
it's kind of like well it's an
incremental report an
incremental thing that's just kind of a
ho-hum
kind of kind of thing and you know
there's a certain value to having those
just because
well you know it's it's a good way of of
kind of
uh concretifying the work you're doing
for myself uh you know i i do science in
a very open way and
so i'm like taking the notebooks you
know i will from notebooks that
i create sort of every night and they
get uploaded to the
to the cloud and people can look at them
and i'm doing a lot of things that are
live streamed and so on and occasionally
i'll write something
which gets put out in this sort of
public writings uh
area and so on and and uh
so for me there's a lot of ways to kind
of um uh
concretify the incremental progress that
i'm making for lots of kind of academic
scientists
really the only way to do that is to
write a paper even if that paper is only
very very incremental
and and not that exciting to read i
think that the thing
you know when people say
people people sometimes think that a
clearly written paper
oh it must all be easy if you can
explain it that clearly
well uh no it's actually often very hard
takes a lot of intellectual effort to
explain things clearly
and to make it seem simple so to speak
and sometimes
in in academic paper writing that sort
of defeats itself because
you make it seem very simple and then
people will react to it
and say oh it can't be very very deep
because it seems so simple
but the fact that it seems so simple you
know you put a lot of effort into making
it seem simple it's kind of like the
paradox of
you have different products and one of
them is more expensive than others you
know you might think or people are going
to buy the cheaper product but actually
some of the time it's like well i want
the really high quality version i'm
going to buy the more expensive one even
though
really that doesn't actually probably
isn't anything different about it
except that it's more expensive so to
speak and that can happen with research
papers as well
it looks fancier and so it must be
have deeper things to say even if you
don't really understand it even if it
wasn't written clearly enough
that people can understand it but in
terms of
of um sort of stages of life to um to
write research papers i mean i i would
say that
doing research is a thing worth doing
as early as you can i mean i started
doing these things when i was
probably 12 years old something like
that
doing sort of researchy type things and
um
uh sort of haven't looked back since um
i think it's uh it's really worthwhile
although it's important to kind of get
the right questions
and um you know starting from questions
that seem obvious to you to ask
that's a really good place to start now
in terms of
of you know what are the venues if you
write your great research paper what do
you do with it
there are a number of online venues
which are steadily getting a little bit
more buttoned down and
and um a little bit less anything goes
tight places but
but there are there are plenty of venues
if you're doing stuff with wolfram
language there's our wolf and community
uh uh forum which is a good place to to
post things and
people make comments and so on it's a
it's sort of a good interactive place
then when it gets a little bit fancier
they're the various pre-print servers
and so on
and then there are academic journals
academic journals can be kind of messy
and
and a little bit of a negative to
interact with because
you know you'll send your paper into an
academic journal and you'll get back
some kind of report from an anonymous
reviewer that says oh i didn't
understand this paper i think it's all
nonsense
and you'll be like who is this person
that's you know they just didn't get it
they didn't bother to read what i wrote
and it's it can be a bit dispiriting
i think for people to get those kinds of
responses
and a lot of the story of of academic
sort of peer reviewing is
is ultimately rather it's sort of an in
game where people are referring to each
other in their papers and it's kind of
like a
like a whole weird sort of sociological
ecosystem
which if you're sort of coming from the
outside and you're you know a
high school student college student
whatever um it's
it's sort of a little bit tough to break
into that and i wouldn't
you know in in today's world getting
your paper sort of uh
officially published in the finest
journal not that people necessarily know
what the finance journal even is anymore
is probably not the most important thing
if you're in an early stage of
career having having the thing out there
and having people respond
to it um is uh you know is is a big part
of it and whether it gets that
the stamp of approval of some mysterious
organization
saying we're going to publish it in our
journal now is probably less important
than than other things
so uh it's a few comments on research
papers all right we've got um
uh so many questions here
um okay there's a question from
kube here uh what do i think of research
and engineering
isn't it better to work in a company
that specializes in a certain field and
knows it in and out and come up with
something revolutionary
instead of working at a university where
everything is rather theoretical uh
good question about engineering it's
really a question of motivation i mean
if you work at a company and you're part
of some
great project and you make some key
contributions and that project is used
by millions of people
for many people that's an extremely
satisfying thing to have happen
for other people it's like well you know
do people know
with me me me is my name on that thing
that can be a motivator
and that's often not what happens at
companies
you know i i was always some uh at our
company
many years ago i am uh
was very concerned because that people
are making great contributions to things
and it's like oh i'd like the world to
know you made these great contributions
and so on
and it was interesting because some
people were like oh yes i want people to
know this
and others were things like no no don't
put my name on that stuff i'm going to
get technical support
questions about this piece of software
if my name is on it i don't want that
i want to feel the sort of pride and
achievement of producing the software
that lots of people are going to use but
i don't want my name on it because
i don't want to kind of you know get all
those
sort of random tech support that i don't
care about having the me flag
on the thing so you know
and there's a flip side to that like uh
you know
my company is called will from research
and we have this product called wolf and
alpha and so
you know my name is on lots of these
things there comes a point
where in a sense it's a it's a sort of a
story of branding you've you've built
some some set of things and it's kind of
like
i'm donating my name to these things to
sort of co-brand them and that that
that's a somewhat different dynamic it's
a i've i've often thought
there's a certain set of people uh who
named their companies after themselves
out there in the world
whether it's you know michael dell or
mike bloomberg or myself or you know
lots of people who've named their
companies after themselves and
there's some industries like i don't
know law firms or something where
where they're always named after the
people who start them and
the question is what is in common
between all these people who name things
after themselves
and you might have thought it was
absolute rabid egotism but it's
absolutely not
it's it's you're building something and
you care about that thing
and you sort of take responsibility for
the thing
and that's what ends up with people
putting their names on things
and uh and usually there's a force in a
high technology world
to have founders not put their names on
things because
if the companies are are primarily
supported by investors
the investors don't want to have the
thing where it's called you know
uh smith incorporated and you know
then the investors are pushing out smith
because they think jones would do a
better job
and but they still stuck with this
company being called smith incorporated
and you know for investors it's much
better if the name of the company is
just
you know company x because then it's
sort of plug compatible who's running
the company
um and uh i think it's uh you know one
can argue about whether that's a good
idea or a bad idea
but um so you know in terms of of
engineering
yes in many kinds of engineering the
leading edge
is happening in companies not at
universities the things that happen at
universities
tend to be more on the oh that's going
to be important in 20
you know 10 20 years that type of thing
whereas in a company it's what's going
to be important in a year or two kind of
thing
and again sometimes there are exciting
things that are going to be important in
20 years
sometimes it's like there's a in a field
that's sort of rapidly moving it's going
to be things that are that are exciting
in the next few years
i think that um the other thing can
happen at universities
is and it's it happened for a while
particularly in things like the software
world
it's like one would have a situation i
think it's less true now but it was true
maybe
25 years ago quite a bit it was like
there were two kinds of software there
was software that was intended for
people to use
and the software that was intended for
people to write a paper about
and the software that was intended for
people to use that was mostly happening
in companies
and but then there was software which
was just like it's a cool thing
and we can write a paper about of course
it doesn't really work properly
it doesn't really it's not something
people can really use but it's a cool
thing and we can write a paper about it
and that's a different motivation and a
different thing that that one's getting
done and and some of that
in moderation some of that can be very
valuable because it's doing things where
to build the whole real working thing
would be a huge amount of work and cost
a lot of money and all those kinds of
things
but we can still talk about it and the
ideas are interesting at sort of a more
academic level
but i would say in terms of people uh
doing work
it really depends on you know are you
interested in being part of a team
that's going to be
sort of doing something where it could
be important in the world here and now
or do you want to are you more
interested in being doing something
where
sort of you're the one exposing it to
the world and you're the one
sort of presenting it and that's more
tends to be more of an academic kind of
thing
um okay let's see uh
[Music]
oh gosh a lot of very different
questions here
um
all right this question from nelson here
uh
revealing that nelson may not be the kid
for whom who is supposed to be the the
center of this um
uh of the demographic for my my sessions
here but nelson says
about 20 years ago i heard about
holographic storage
what happened with this kind of
technology that didn't go forward
okay so first question is well okay so
in a computer one of the critical
elements is the memory how do you store
this
digital information how do you store the
collection of bits that represents your
document your image your video
your program whatever else and
there are essentially all computers now
use
a particular method of storing that
information
which is uh well it's usually cmos metal
complementary metal oxide semiconductor
technology it's it's using
uh using silicon which is a
semiconductor
um to to store those bits but i can
explain a bit about how that works
and then we can talk about the many
different variations of that
that have been tried over the course of
time to make better stronger faster
uh versions of how to store things
so essentially well let's see how come
let me explain several different kinds
of storage
so um
it used to be the case and is to some
extent still the case
that for very large scale storage of
digital information
the most common thing to use is magnetic
materials
and used to be the case that one would
have discs which would spin around
and and what would happen is well okay
so i should explain
how do you store so you're storing
digital information so in the end
everything you're storing is turned into
sequences
of ones and zeros or ons and offs and
in a typical memory of a modern computer
you might have
uh a trillion bits of of uh
maybe a little less maybe a hundred
billion uh sort of
uh ones and zeros that are being stored
a 100
100 billion bits of information each bit
is just whether it's a
a one or a zero so
one way to store that is with magnetic
materials
okay so in a magnetic material like uh
for example uh iron uh
iron is magnetic and what that means is
that it can you can you can make a
magnet out of iron
but what happens is inside the iron
there are these electrons that are each
little
act like little tiny microscopic bar
magnets
and essentially what's happening is the
iron the the electrons sort of close
enough together in the iron
that they can when one of them is lined
up in a certain direction it will tend
to lead other ones to line up in the
same direction
and pretty soon you can get all the
electrons so to speak all of the
particular kind of electrons in iron
so all line up so that they're so that
they're all contributing
something they're all acting like little
bar magnets all pointed in the same
direction
and so that's how you produce a magnet
that you can like you know an iron
magnet you can like pick things up with
and so on
okay so iron has this characteristic
it's what's called a ferromagnet
um or a ferromagnetic material and it
has the characteristic that
the electrons sort of close enough
together that they
will if they're going to be lined up
they'll all line up so you get this big
magnetic uh field okay so there's
another type of material called a fairy
magnet
with an i instead of an o and a fairy
magnet
you can get little domains where things
are where
all the electrons are effectively lined
up but it doesn't
extend over the whole material it
doesn't extend to your whole bar magnet
it's just a little domain
where where the where the things are
lined up and
so what what was done in uh magnetic
tapes magnetic disks
things like this what was done is
if you if you have a little bit of
magnitude if you have a little magnetic
field
you can line up the electrons
effectively in these small regions of
the ferry magnet
and what you can do is you can say this
particular place
on this particular disk represents this
particular bit
if there's magnetism in this particular
position if the magnets
if if the um if the electrons are lined
up in this direction at this particular
position that represents a one
if they're lined up in the opposite
direction it represents a zero
and so what's done is
you basically have this this material
and it can be in different kinds of
shapes it can come as tape where it's a
just a long a long thing that you spool
out
um or it can be in a disc where it's
just a circular
object where they're little tiny sectors
of the disk
where each position there is
whatever at that position it's like
either going to be magnetized up or down
so to speak
which represents either there's a one or
a zero at that position
and so then uh what happens is there
will be a head
that reads and writes the the bits
from that magnetic material so for
example if it's a tape
the tape would be just running past some
head and at that head it's either
well roughly either magnetizing or
demagnetizing
or you can think of it as either having
magnetic field in one direction or the
other
usually it actually works by magnetism
and demagnetizing but it doesn't really
matter how
that that's a detail of of of how it's
set up
but basically what's happening is in in
tiny tiny regions
you know tiny fractions of a of a
million to a meter across
you are having this is the position
where we're representing the value of
this bit this is the position
we're representing the value of this bit
and so on and so
you're storing data by storing the
pattern of magnetism
in these particular kinds of things now
in the case of magnetic disk
the thing is spinning around usually it
spins around at about 60 revolutions per
second
um and uh which is the the frequency of
the
of um uh the electrical supply in a
country like us
sometimes 50 hertz and some other
countries um
the uh so the thing is spinning around
and it has a head that is
able to read uh that's able to go to a
particular position so that the head
kind of goes in and out
and as the disc turns around if you want
to
get the head to a particular position
you basically wait
until the disc has turned around so that
that sector of the disc
is under the head and then you've
arranged that the head is either
uh pushed in or out to the kind of uh
radial position of the particular piece
of data you're trying to to read or
write
and fancier disk drives will have many
heads and so on
but essentially what's happening is
you're reading and writing data by just
uh by by by having the the disk turn
around to the point where the head is
over
the particular place where that
particular piece of data is written
and then the head can either read that
piece of data or it can write something
new
in that particular position and that's
basically how magnetic storage works
and magnetic storage can be it can be
kind of slow
to read or write data because you have
to wait for that physical disk to turn
around
to the position it's only 160 of a
second but in computer time
160 of the second is a long time and you
have to kind of wait for the disc to be
in that position
to get to the point where you can read
or write the data from it
so that's for a long time sort of
large-scale storage and still to some
extent true large-scale storage was done
using very magnetic materials these
kinds of magnetic
this this effect of having these local
regions where you would magnetize or not
magnetize
or magnetize in different directions
representing ones and zeros representing
bits in your data
okay so the way most computers actually
do it these days is they use
um semiconductor chips and what's
happening there not sure what level of
detail maybe let me not go
too too high level of detail but what's
basically happening is
there's uh there are
these essentially uh switches
that are created by by transistors and
transistors
on on a chip you have the semiconductor
what is a semiconductor
well normally there are things which
conduct electricity like metals
you can make wires out of metal and you
know electricity electrons which
represent the electricity
will flow through the wire they will
freely flow
through the wire from one end to the
other that's the first thing
then there are insulators um things
uh that are you know like i don't know
uh
i know wood or styrofoam or or any of
these kinds of things
it's pretty good insulator um or
plastic or lots of kinds of things um
insulators have the property of
electrons do not travel through them
electrons get stuck electrons are still
you know electrons exist in atoms and
they don't get to get outside of their
atoms the electrons
can't get to the point where they can
sort of roam freely in the material
electrons are always stuck inside atoms
okay semiconductors are part way in the
middle so the way it works is
electrons will either be stuck inside
atoms or if you kind of
increase the energy of the electrons
they can reach what's called the
conduction band
which is a place where the electrons are
no longer bound to an individual atom
but can kind of roam freely in the
material that's how metals work
is they the electrons that roam freely
are in this conduction band
slightly higher energy and so they are
they're able to
roam around the metal and when you put a
voltage on the metal you're pushing the
electrons
through from one end to the other okay
so semiconductors work a little bit
differently
and what what happens with a
semiconductor is if you're not putting a
sort of a big voltage the the thing will
just sit there
and you know with all the electrons sort
of stuck inside their atoms
if you put a certain voltage it's often
six volts like for silicon
sort of a critical number if you put
that voltage if you're pushing the
electrons
with that sort of amount of force the
electrons will get
sort of will be allowed will be sort of
taken away from their atoms
and they will get into a conduction band
and they will be able to sort of roam
freely in the semiconductor so sort of
if you push them hard enough they'll
kind of roam freely and
so that that means it's different from
an insulator where they don't run freely
at all
or from a metal where they run freely
all the time
and so if you sort of push it hard
enough it will roam freely
and that mechanism can be used to make
essentially switches
where you're saying uh if if you you
you're trying to you're getting a
current to go from
from this place to that place and
depending on the voltage
in the middle um you'll you'll either
it'll either allow the current to pass
or not that makes the so-called field
effect transistor
and the that can be done in
semiconductors like silicon silicon is
the most famous the most widely used
semiconductor
and uh there's there's a lot of detail
about exactly how you do that with
doping the semiconductor with different
kinds of materials and you essentially
make these features on the semiconductor
by etching them uh by by cutting away
layers
of the semiconductor that have slightly
different characteristics
and the way you make a memory a memory
chip
is there are lots of uh uh pairs of
of transistors basically which together
make a um um
uh can make a sort of a a thing which
either can be
sort of having a roughly a circulating
current of electrons or not having a
circulating current or electrons
it's not quite right but that's a good
approximation
okay so that allows you to make uh so
so in a you'll have these chips where
there's just an array of billions
of these little tiny tiny pieces that
have a few transistors in them
that correspond to something where as
soon as you've got some sort of current
or roughly
of electrons in there just sort of stays
circulating around
until you tell it to stop and that's how
you store the memory
and so there are typically two kinds of
two general kinds of um
uh of kinds of ram random access memory
it's called random access memory
because unlike a a disk for example
where you like have to wait for the
for the disk to turn around and get to a
particular position to read that bit
in random access memory it's just a pure
electronic issue
of saying oh i want to i have these i
have this whole array of wires that come
into the chip
and i can just say i want to read the
particular bit at this position
and it can that can happen immediately
and it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't
have to wait for a disk to turn around
or anything
like that so it's random access memory
you can access it randomly wherever you
want
at any position you want rather than
having to wait for that particular
position
to sort of come around as the disc turns
so they cook two general kinds static
ram dynamic ram
so roughly in in in
dynamic ram which is what's most common
in computers
this it's a little current effectively
decays
and you have to kind of every uh how
often is it
a few times a second i think you have to
you have to sort of give it a kick
to keep to keep that bit sort of uh
maintained in the memory um so if you if
you like
uh you know if the power goes out and
there's no backup battery or anything
then the memory is just lost whereas
static ram
um you can uh it is slightly slower to
read and write things but you can have
the memory preserved
even when the power is turned off so
okay so that's how
typical modern um uh storage devices
work is using semiconductor memory and
memory chips
and um uh just to confuse things these
things called
state disks or ssds which kind of
look to a computer like a disk like one
of these things that turns around
but actually they're solid state which
means they're really semiconductor
memory
okay so there are all kinds of variants
that people have tried
on semiconductor memory for example for
example another one is so-called flash
memory
um where the um
which is similar to semiconductor memory
but has slightly different
characteristics
you have to kind of blast it with a lot
of energy to write a bit
but then reading the bit is easier so it
can be so
very slow or even you can only write it
once in some cases
there are cases where you can have
things like um
you have a memory like eeproms which are
uh where
you can you can write it once and then
um
and then just stays there unless you
expose it to ultraviolet light
and then you destroy the memory that's
there um
and there are various different variants
like that but people have been
interested in are there completely
different ways to store digital
information
and there have been a variety of things
tried so
one approach is to store the information
using
uh things based on light
okay so uh how does a a cd-rom
which probably older people here will
certainly know what that is
or a dvd how does a dvd work
it's a it's a it's a thing where there
are
um it's it's like that magnetic disk
except that the the data is not stored
magnetically
it's not stored as something which you
can detect using an electrical device
it's stored optically and what happens
is
the the in all these sort of uh in all
these different positions on this disk
for a dvd for example
um dvd stands for digital video disc
in all these different positions on the
disc
you will have something which either
where
it either absorbs light or doesn't
absorb light
and so then what happens is you have a
little tiny laser
and you shine that laser on that
particular position
on this disc and depending on what's on
at that position on the disc the laser
light will either be reflected back
or not and that's how you represent the
one or the zero
now when you create a dvd
you're doing it usually by essentially a
a physical printing process
you're not doing it like you do in
computer memory where you have
an electrical process for the computer
that's writing the data
instead you're you're just um uh
you're you're creating it once and for
all and um
uh and then um
uh and then you're able to read it as
many times as you want
so um the uh
um
somebody is commenting here that static
ram is volatile and i'm
i'm getting myself
let's see the uh
uh all right let me try to remember how
this all works um
somebody can perhaps explain to me um
and usually there is uh
now we have to we have to backtrack a
bit so i was explaining about
how different kinds of computer memory
either require some uh
refresh every uh every some amount of
time or do not
and um
let's see the um i have to remember
what um the the kind of thing that
doesn't are so-called read-only memories
where i think what's happening is uh
that you're you're sort of blasting it
through um
okay okay okay the all right so i'm
being i'm being
reminded that uh good well
my memory is not perfect here um
static ram it says it's fast and
expensive dynamic ram is less expensive
and slower um so
uh i don't know the details off hand of
how that works
um i mean i think that the um
uh there are different configurations of
transistors that you end up using to
store bits or not
and um there are
a ways that you can sort of blast things
with enough current
that you kind of permanently change the
structure of the um
uh uh of the kind of um
the circuit um but that's not what's
happening in in
ordinary ram that's what's happening in
in uh various kinds of read-only
memories where you just
blast the data in once and then you're
going to read it many times
but okay so there's something for me to
learn here um
but anyway back back to back to optical
kinds of storage so
the most um the uh
uh the sort of most obvious way of
having a dvd work
is you you kind of um uh you kind of
print out the dvd once and it has you
know
all sorts of details at the level of of
the
positions of individual bits and you get
to read it there were some
technologies like writable dvds
where you would have a higher intensity
laser that could
actually etch out uh that could do
things like i don't know whether it
actually melted the material or how it
worked
to or maybe it had a material that was
sensitive to very
high intensity light that had some kind
of um
uh uh nonlinear optical effect
but any case that was the technology
that seemed to be popular for a little
while
um but i think was quite slow to write
data to
and then uh but then
there's a question so so in terms of uh
you know it's it's when you have an
optical material
you can have you have some material
where you're where you're
sort of not quite changing its color but
changing the way that it
reacts to light that's a way to store
things but it's not very easy
to change that on the fly having said
that there are
electro optic materials which do allow
you to change it on the fly
using electrical effects but i don't
think that's a a common storage
mechanism
so the i mean
the idea of uh so there
are different kinds of approaches one
can take to
to storing data and uh
it's really a question of a lot of
trade-offs in how long does the data
last
there you really need some element that
where you can push it in some way
it will go into a different state and it
will stay in that state
and so people have done things like for
example there was a big enthusiasm
amount of enthusiasm
of using superconductors which are
materials where
electrical currents can just be set up
in the material and they just keep going
forever
the problem with superconductors is all
the ones we know uh operate only at very
low temperatures
so you end up with at least liquid
nitrogen if not liquid helium
cooling your your device and so there
are things called joseph's injunctions
that uh sort of have have these more or
less circulating currents
and uh that you can read and write with
magnetic fields and that was popular i
don't know
30 years ago or something there was a
bout of enthusiasm for that those things
are coming back
in in current generation kind of quantum
computers
um but there are there are a series of
different kinds of methods that people
have thought about
as ways to kind of store things now the
ultimate way to store things
is to have a molecule and to have
individual configurations of atoms in
the molecule
because you know in the current and
current semiconductor storage devices
you're using around 100 000 electrons
per bit that you store
the the the total number of electrons is
around 100 000
and uh maybe it's maybe it's down to
tens of thousands now but i think it's i
think it's still around 100 000
electrons per bit
and you would you ask yourself could we
make an example
of something where there is a molecule
where individual configurations of atoms
um
in the molecule are um
uh um
uh are storing
the data and obviously we have one very
good example of that which is in
us the dna that we have there are bases
that are you know the ac gt
different bases which are clumps of
atoms not very big
that uh can be stuck onto this backbone
and for us we have altogether six
billion of these
stuck on this backbone um and wound up
in double helixes and
unable to be replicated and all those
kinds of things but fundamentally
we're storing data in dna and dna is a
fairly stable molecule unlike rna
um it's a fairly stable molecule which
is why we can like extract dna from
uh you know frozen critters that
have been frozen for you know for a
million years or something
and um expect that the dna won't have
kind of self-destructed
so dna is an example of a molecule on
which we can store things
it's not very fast right now to read out
the data from that dna
for example we read it out when we build
proteins but that uses this whole
elaborate apparatus that takes
milliseconds to seconds
to actually operate so it's not very
good for sort of nanosecond or less
scale you know billionth of a second
scale
computer kind of applications but so you
know the sort of holy grail
of of storing things is to store things
in molecules
and to store them a very high density
where small clumps of atoms
are sensitive are what um um
what's needed to to store things and we
don't yet know
a systematic way to get things stored
down at the level of molecules we have
the example of dna
that biology has provided us with but um
uh we'd really like to have
other what are called heteropolymers
where polymer is just a chemical which
is a repeat of the same element many
many times
a heteropolymer means it's a it's a sort
of a repeat of things but there's a
change
um you can have you can sort of swap in
and out different elements
in this long chain and that's that's how
dna works and we'd like to have other
kinds of molecules where we can store
information
at that level we don't yet know how to
do that i think it's a sort of coming
attraction for molecular scale computing
all right let me see um
now if somebody if somebody posts to me
an explanation of how
static versus dynamic ram work i can
tell everybody else
um
uh oh there's a question from pale blue
here
why do dvds um
need to spin these days why not just
scan top to bottom directly into memory
that's an interesting question well the
reason you want the dvd to spin is
because you're not just scanning it into
memory i mean you're usually actually
well maybe you are maybe you just want
to read the dvd into memory
then the answer to that question is
because that's the way the machines were
originally built
and why changed them now you know if one
was reading one of those vinyl records
these days
it might be better instead of actually
having a
you know record player with a needle
going up and down in the vinyl
grooves to actually have a very high
resolution
optical system and just scan it from top
to bottom that might be a better
solution but i think with dvd technology
it's still like well we've got a dvd
reader why not use the dvd reader
um there's a question from bobby about
how does dvd rw that's the read write
um and i think the answer is it uses a
higher intensity laser
to be able to to sort of zap the plastic
in the dvd um
let's see
uh
all right um
let's see it's a question from jonas
here follow up to question about storing
information is there present
optical end-to-end computers
where everything works optically um
would it be easier or harder to have a
multi-valued obstacle computer not
binary than an electronic one
okay so the answer is
there aren't really yet sort of
full-scale
optical computers i think there will be
and i think
i just was seeing some article i've been
saying this is going to happen for like
decades
that people are going to talk about
quantum computers but they're really
going to make optical computers
what is an optical computer an optical
computer
instead of using electrons and
electricity
is just using uh very small amounts of
light
as the thing to represent information so
it's like either there is
is light here or there isn't light here
the light comes in photons just like
electricity comes in electrons
and so what one's doing is once having
sort of interactions
uh once having photons be used to
transmit information around
now usually what happens is the question
is can you make something like a
transistor
for optics can you make kind of an
optical analog of a transistor an
optical analog
of a kind of switch where you're you're
having
one thing that's controlling for example
whether light can go through or not
where you can sort of use light to
control whether light can go through
something
well to do that you have to use
so-called nonlinear optics
so generally light doesn't interact much
with itself
for all practical purposes you have two
light beams you have two laser beams
you can shine them right through each
other that the photons will just go
straight through without interacting
there is a very tiny quantum effect that
causes so-called light by light
scattering that causes photons to
to actually interact with each other but
it's an incredibly incredibly tiny
effect
for ordinary visible light photons
becomes more significant when you have
very high energy photons
but uh like in gamma rays and so on but
even even there you have to it's very
still a very small effect
but so in a first approximation like
just just go straight through things
and you can't you know you get two beams
of light to
to interact with each other to to do
something where for example
you make a logical gait where you say
only let something through
if both this photon and this photon are
present
but otherwise don't that's something
that is more difficult to do
okay how do you do it well you can do it
by using nonlinear optical elements
and there are a variety of different
kinds of non-air optical elements
and there are also optical elements that
interact with electricity electro optics
where let's see where does one see those
um
the uh i think you have been on a 787
airplane i think that they
these many of them have um electro-optic
um they use electro optics for their um
uh windows um instead of having a blind
that you pull down
you're just sort of pressing a button
and the and the window goes black
and the way that works is it's it's
putting an electric field
um through this material and when the
material when the electric field is
going through the material
the material uh will make
uh will will stop certain
light from going through it um and uh
and if
you don't put the electric field it
won't um
so but that that's a way to sort of
interact between electricity and light
is to use electro optics to basically
have it be uh the most common things
uh original well it's a these electro
optic elements are things with cur cells
are one one common case
where basically you're you're putting
when there is an electric field when
there's a voltage
across the material the material lines
things up in the material in such
a way that uh light
that is in one polarization that light
where there is effectively the
the variations in the electric field are
in one direction can't get through
and so you can uh and you can make
therefore you can
when you stop that getting through when
you have another cross polarizer you can
prevent any light from getting through
and so on
so that's a way of sort of taking
electricity and light and making them
interact
now light interacting with light more
challenging so an example of how that
can be done
um and i'm not
not sure let's see well here's an
example
so-called saturable absorbers so
normally
if you have a material it's either
transparent or it's not transparent
you put us you put light into it it's
some
uh um the um
you um uh
the thing the thing has some um
uh if it's transparent the light will go
through if it isn't transparent the
light will be stopped
okay there are some materials where if
you've put a lot of light into it
already
it will then become less transparent it
sort of saturates as you put more light
in
you stop being able to get light through
it and roughly that's happening because
as you put the light in you're forcing
some of the atoms and the material to go
into different states
and in those different states they don't
let more light through
and so that's an example of how you can
have light control light so to speak
in one of these systems and there are a
variety of those kinds of components but
i don't think
there is yet invented sort of the
perfect transistor-like switch
for light and that's what you would need
to make sort of really good optical
computers
there are other ways to make kind of
optical computers
oh there's a there's a whole okay there
are some kinds of computations
where it is very natural for them to be
done using light
particularly things called fourier
transforms which are
important in processing signals and in
various kinds of
analysis of data those are things which
very naturally happen with light just by
the nature of the way that
light that
oh i should have explained oh this is
another whole kind of worms
okay so while photons can't interact
with each other you just
shine two beams of light through each
other there is this
uh there are interference effects
well this is more complicated let's i
don't think they're
directly relevant to the way that you
would build um
your typical optical computer at this
point um
the uh um
okay i'm being told that i'm very late
here and nobody reminded me what time it
was so i've
just been yakking on about storage
methods and so on
um but uh so i think we have to we have
to
uh stop here for today um
the uh oh gosh so many interesting
questions here
um and uh
uh all right well um
i think i think i didn't that so i i was
sort of answering a little bit about
optical computers
i think that there is there is every
reason to believe
that one will be able to make optical
computers that run
faster um do better things than
electronic computers
but some of that technology just doesn't
exist yet um
and uh i think that some of the things
that we think of as being
features of quantum computers
particularly the so-called interference
effects
um that um uh will happen
in optical computers and um that may be
something that's useful for doing
computations although
some of the sort of potential magic of
quantum computers which i'm pretty
skeptical about anyway
um will not happen for optical computers
there's some
some magic will happen but some will not
right i should i should wrap up here
and um lots of interesting questions for
next time
thanks for joining us and uh see you
another